so i put out a documentary you know
about the documentary i mean i guess or
maybe not but i didn't know about it
until i got ready to meet you today and
then i was like wow you know so where's
this documentary available it's not
anymore no it's not so what happened was
i spent 1.3 million dollars making this
film
uh we premiered at the director's guild
there was 700 people there sold out
audience
standing room only amazing incredible
and the night we get there we start the
film and it was streaming globally
because i was the first person actually
ever to do a live global streaming
vod premiere and people underpaid to
pay-per-view right did was it successful
it would have been had we not gotten
hacked and pirated okay okay so as the
film started all of a sudden the thing
froze
and
people all over the world who paid money
to see the film could not see it because
there was an interruption of service
it's called a ddos server attack okay
okay so we got a ddos server attack that
shut down the film shut down the stream
they actually copied it they stole the
stream
they copied the script
and then they created a subsidiary
website that was like a copycat website
that went up literally live the moment
our stream came down
and they started selling tickets for
thirty dollars
versus us who was
charging twenty dollars for the ticket
so they're taking the same movie same
stream same script so it looks like the
same website they even pushed it up in
the google search so theirs was mine was
mytruthdoc.com theirs was
mytruthdocs.com
they put up a fake website the same
exact time that our premiere is
happening they shut down yours did they
direct all of your traffic to their page
correct
correct so they would have had to have
been able to uh
to edit your page as well but i guess
they hacked it yeah they hacked it they
stole the stream they copied the script
wow and they were able to build another
prototype of a website that looked
exactly like ours that went live the
moment that ours went down
by the
virgin and then somehow the media just
never talked about it
because the next day was kovid so nobody
wanted to talk about it and so i've
never been on any talk shows the news
won't have me on the i mean like that's
why i say media blackout because all the
mainstream media has prevented me from
coming forth and talking about this
story given that these hackers
uh
actually monetize it they took money
isn't it possible to follow that money
trail and and and get to these people
who committed the copyright yeah you'd
need a lot of expensive lawyers
and a lot of investigators were you able
to to
get any sense of how many buys they did
well we can no i have no idea how much
they how many tickets they sold for
their
you know fake but i know that it was up
for three months
before we even knew about it i found it
by accident actually my my director the
guy who directed the film brian
herslinger text me one day and he goes
hey do you know about this you just you
just you just did a post for our movie
that goes to a different website and i'm
like what and he's like yeah and it was
like an accidental thing like i put my
truths instead of my truth by accident
and you click on it and it's an actual
website but it's not our website and
he's like yeah dude that's an entirely
different website that's not our website
i was like holy [ __ ] and it was uh
and they were selling
so that was multiple different websites
so there was that one that was the main
thing how they were pulling the money
out but the way they liquidated the
movie and made it worthless
was by putting it out for free all over
youtube so they put out about 200 free
links on youtube the first one got 250
000 views
before uh youtube would take it down and
we were sending them letters for weeks
and they wouldn't listen because we
didn't have like you know the exact
right trademark information or the exact
copyright information or whatever and
they like wanted everything by the book
before they would even listen to us that
this is our film even though i paid for
it even though it's my name on it i
produced it it's my lawyer hitting you
up but if you don't have the exact
paperwork they're not gonna listen that
makes me glad that we uh
got gotten business with that
anti-piracy company before putting out
gnarly yeah
we spent like six thousand bucks to get
uh this anti-piracy company to like uh
you know stamp whatever redshift
anywhere my [ __ ] shows up yeah like
that it's gonna be like
you know flat trademark type thing yeah
yeah that's gonna prevent the prevent
from showing up on youtube i was so
naive man i had no idea i thought like
hey i found a foolproof way because look
i put out a book they edited my story i
put out uh a doc
a film on the lifetime network
that you know was a pretty good film
that i helped produce they edited and
changed the story even as far as like
changing the scenes to make it not what
it was supposed to be you know what i
mean so like everything kept getting
changed and edited how are you going to
get the truth out everybody kept saying
you got to get the truth out you got to
get the troop there fine
how do i do this so that nobody is
controlling the narrative
but me
right right well the only way that you
can possibly do that is to put it out in
a documentary format but even then
you've got to get your eno lawyers to
approve everything to make sure you
don't get sued right you can't put out
anything that's like above and beyond
and you have to work really really
really hard to prove that
everything is corroborated like there is
not one thing in that movie that wasn't
corroborated by like multiple people
that it sounded like that those were
some pretty fiery
allegations
right yeah but i'm confused whites where
is it now
was my truth
the rape of two quarries right again and
and even saying the word rape on youtube
i think uh gets here
have you not talked about it since then
i have not taught this is this the first
time
you said that this documentary is not
available but so did you ultimately get
it all taken down from youtube yeah so
we got them finally taken down but so
250 000 views at 20 a pop how much money
is that 250 000 views at 20 dollars
5 million
more
250 million wait 250 50 million i'm bad
enough 250 000 views at 20 20
i think it's five it's five million
twenty divided by four
yeah it's uh
because divided by 250 though
it's a quarter million 250 times two is
five hundred thousand maybe i'm good and
then you add one zero because it's a
twenty six five million
i don't think so
maybe that's just one of the links and
then you know
whatever no that was definitely just one
of the links but the point is all
together it came out to like 80 million
dollars i mean what it would have been
it would have been a lucrative business
play
it wasn't and we weren't doing it for
that you know at the end of the day we
just wanted to get the truth out but i
had bills i have to pay back people that
like a whole crew that was working on on
spec
you know that was looking forward to it
doing well and getting paid and then on
top of it what we could have done with
the prophets
would have been unbelievable i'm not
good at math either by the way so it
could totally be dude
i don't even know but we should pull out
a calculator
somebody already has don't worry
somebody's in there like you're an
[ __ ] yeah on the comments
you're an [ __ ] you don't know how to
do math go bite yourself
they won't even have me on to explain
what happened to my film we're talking
about 100 million dollars worth of you
know liquid corruption that just
happened tax evasion who's who's paying
the taxes on all that money that went
through those fingertips i mean where's
all that advertising money all that you
know if you can't trace down the people
and the money for a copyright claim not
only that but they were making dvds
they literally had dvds with the
packaging with the artwork with
everything in your life presumably
presumably the documentary
you know
even though you didn't uh
make any money off of it right some
people made money off it and plenty of
people saw it so how is the documentary
critically reviewed amazingly okay
amazingly yeah i mean like anybody
that's giving an honest review of it
like okay so what happened was they
tried to act like it didn't happen at
all like i did actually read news
stories the next morning that said it
was all lie corey was scamming his fans
there was no movie
unfortunately what they didn't expect is
they didn't expect that i would have two
separate copies so we had the copy that
was streaming
uh for the whole world to see and then
we had a separate copy that was the
premier copy of the dga so i actually
stopped the film 15 minutes in and said
look guys i don't know if i should
finish the movie because it's been
hacked online
and it's not really fair to all the
people who paid to not get to see the
movie at the same time as you so i was
thinking about not even playing the rest
of it at the premiere and coming back
and doing it a separate day once we got
it all worked out and it was actually a
bunch of actors who rushed the stage um
you know like roseanne arquette was one
of them and she was the most vocal and
she got to the front of the stage she
said corey you need to do this now she's
like do not back down she goes that's
what they want they want you to stop the
film they want you to not play it she
said but if you do this you're never
going to get all of us back here again
you're never going to get a whole
premiere full of people like it's never
going to happen
and i was like you know what she's right
and so because of that i continued the
film and i played the whole movie out
and so the next day you added in
rolling stone l.a times entertainment
weekly everybody reviewed the movie and
said it was a good movie and we did the
thing
you know
but then everybody that wasn't in the
room tried to say that the movie never
played there was no movie there was no
there there it was a nothing burger blah
blah blah blah blah
so for people who are listening to this
and they're just dying to see this movie
are you really telling them that it's
not available i can't it can't because
number one i had to pull it i had to
pull it because of the safety of my my
life and my family you know there was
two attempts on my life leading up to
this which are documented in the movie
um the lapd for whatever reason will not
give us the video footage to prove that
i was actually attacked because people
tried to say that the attack never
happened that's the way they spun it the
lapd officer for whatever reason after
photo i mean i have video footage of
them photographing the the wound and and
sizing the the scar and the laceration
right they're literally like like sizing
it and taking pictures of it in the
hospital
they turned around and said there was no
puncture wound yeah wow somebody tried
to stab you in the back of the neck in
this side it was very tiny i mean it
wasn't
they literally it was a godsend i don't
know how i can't explain it but they
missed so they didn't get very far they
just got like the very tip of the knife
into me so i thought it was like maybe a
needle because i couldn't figure it out
i remember the story being that you
thought it was somebody who was trying
to dermic needle yeah i didn't know but
then later on when i was showing the
jacket that i got stabbed into the cops
we saw a slit this big so you know that
it was a knife because there was a slit
in the jacket okay so anyway so i went
and filed a subpoena to lapd for the
freedom of information act and said i
know you guys have the footage you
showed me the footage you can't see what
they're doing but you can easily see
that they break into my car and they
reach in and they do something right
right give me that footage from my
documentary where did this attack take
place
in on ventura boulevard when and was it
and what was the night
this is just random you were there it
wasn't random
they followed me they followed me from
where i was eating but it wasn't at like
uh the screening of your movie or no no
no no i was having dinner actually with
the director and my friend jamison
newlander who played the other frog
brother and we were actually discussing
and i was showing them what i call my
bible of evidence and i was showing them
everything telling them everything that
happened up to that point and why i felt
it was necessary to make this
documentary asking brian if he was
interested in you know being a part of
it and honestly he's sitting there
looking at me like is this guy lost his
mind like maybe he's gone crazy this is
like over he didn't believe any of it
and until he saw what happened to me
yeah because i left there that night and
i got followed and all this [ __ ] went
down and i ended up in the hospital the
next day so the the attack happened
while you were making the documentary
then before we made the documentary
before right so then the documentary
came out you released it right since
it's been released were there other
threats or something that makes you want
to
like retract that and not leave it out
yeah i mean first of all it's a constant
non-stop barrage on twitter on social
media um they're constantly gaslighting
me they're trying to accuse me of things
that i never did
um you know basically what happened was
they sent some spies into my life which
are the girls that were part of my angel
tour a couple of the musicians were not
actual musicians they were spies that
were put into my life to cause mayhem
and destruction they're called the
honeypot crazy yeah basically same kind
of deal
so so these girls were put in there to
basically cause mayhem and disarray
and then when i fired them because of
the mayhem and disarray they turned
around and made false allegations about
me which were investigated by lapd and i
was cleared of those false allegations
yet they keep throwing them out there
and they keep adding names to the list
like oh there's like 10 girls who've
come forward there's no 10 girls but
they pretend that there's these fake
names so it's three girls that were sent
into my um tour bus basically and we
know who sent them there and they were
put there on purpose to make me look bad
and then make false allegations but then
they start adding names of like other
people that either we know some of the
names we don't even know who they are
we've never even met these people and
they just make these names and they and
they and they basically put a list out
there and they put it under false
allegations and it's tied to
for a while was actually tied to this
girl named mindy who is uh running to be
a politician who claimed that she knew
all this stuff about me like i've never
even
spent more than maybe like two nights
with her and nothing happened and like
basically she was there as a
date we went on a date but she was gonna
maybe be part of my angel thing and then
i just decided against it she just
didn't you know have the right vibe and
i wasn't into it and that never went
forward so she was like okay when were
these guys sent into your tour bus well
basically the tour bus itself i mean
this is i don't even know how much of
this i should say
i mean whatever like that doesn't matter
what kind of tour bus
it was a very nice one yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude